you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news coming up on today's
programme
paying farmers to adopt climate-friendly
practices the new proposals from the
government rewarding re-wilding and
biodiversity
new research finds air pollution in
urban areas around the world contributed
to 1.8 million excess deaths in 2019
and the new plants discovered last year
from a ghost orchid to a tree named
after a famous actor
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and challenge those coming up with the
solutions
and we start today with new plans from
the government to pay farmers and
landowners to adopt nature and
climate-friendly practices
agriculture is thought to be responsible
for around 10 percent of the uk's
greenhouse gas emissions and now in a
post-brexit change of policy
money will be available to fund
large-scale long-term projects that
store carbon and boost nature now these
could be rewilding landscapes creating
new nature reserves or improving
biodiversity
but environmental groups have criticized
a lack of detail in the proposals here's
what the environment secretary george
eustis had to say earlier we can i think
far more sustainably and that's why our
policy is going to be putting in place
powerful incentives to support
sustainable farming um sensitive
hedgerow management a good stewardship
of soils and a focus on soil health and
biodiversity within our soils
allowing hedgerows to recover
recognizing them as probably the single
most important ecological building block
in the farmed landscape and then of
course recognizing as well that there
will be some land use change you cannot
deliver the targets we have for
new woodland creation at 10 000 hectares
a year and you cannot deliver our
ambition to restore habitats to their
natural state in around 300 000 hectares
unless there is a degree of land use
change well joining me now is tom
bradshaw vice president of the national
farmers union welcome to you tom
bradshaw when the uk was part of the eu
farmers were given grants based on how
much land they farmed
these plans are based on
payments for farming environmentally so
do you welcome the changes
the way that george eustis spoke about
it just then i think that he spelled
that a very attractive picture the
critical thing is we want to be
producing sustainable food alongside
environmental delivery british farmers
are very proud of the standards we
produce our food to and we already
believe we're delivering a lot for the
environment of course we can do more but
really now it's about the incentives
that government put in place to make
sure that we are able to deliver
alongside sustainable food production
and are the incentives adequate is there
enough money to persuade farmers to move
to more sustainable practices
and this is the challenge we're seeing
at the moment that when the sustainable
farming incentive was rolled out early
in december the initial payment rates
really don't look that attractive and
particularly for those that have got to
substantially change the way they farm
it really doesn't appear that they're
going to attract a big enough uptake we
know the ambition for defra is to have
over 70 of the land farmed under the
sustainable farming incentive we would
like to see it even higher than that but
i do believe the incentives will need to
be bigger to make sure that we really
are able to produce truly sustainable
food alongside biodiversity recovery
carbon capture and managing
for clean water and clean air
various groups have come out today and
said they'd like to see more detail
they're saying it's nearly six years
since the referendum
they should know more about what's in
store for them would you agree with that
criticism
we would agree with that i think when
you know what the destination looks like
it's very easy to start putting a plan
in place as to how you're going to get
there and what we're seeing at the
moment is the policy is being rolled out
a little bit sort of a drip drip drip
and we don't know exactly what the end
goal is so we need to see the detail we
need to see all the building blocks and
then farmers across the country will be
able to invest in the future and make
sure they get to the destination that
defra trying to take us to and so we we
absolutely critically need that detail
so that we can start the plan for the
long term and what about tenant farmers
who farm a lot of the land about a third
of the land i think in the uk
is it clear what these new schemes mean
for them
now our biggest fear at the moment is
how does this work for for food
production but also for the tenanted
sector and a third of the land in the
country is spawned by tenants uh it
could be quite attractive particularly
when you look at the rewilding uh areas
and the
nature recovery for for landlords to
take land back in hand and what is the
role of a tenant farmer going to be how
will they be able to access the schemes
and to get that 70 uptake it's going to
be absolutely crucial that it works for
the landowner it works for the tenant
and critically it needs to work for food
production
tom bradshaw thanks very much indeed for
your time
thank you
in today's other climate news
conservation charity trillian trees has
launched an online investment tool to
improve forest restoration
organizations can use the tool to find
out if their tree planting initiatives
will really reach climate goals the
projects are marked out of 27 with the
scores indicating areas that should be
considered such as which tree species
are planted and the involvement of local
communities
and coral reef fisheries which support
communities all over the world are more
resilient to climate change than
originally believed a study led by
lancaster university reveals that
despite bleaching events the fish caught
at the reefs can remain rich sources of
micronutrients this finding is critical
as continued global warming means coral
bleaching events are becoming more
frequent and more severe placing greater
stress on vulnerable ecosystems
and a new species of tropical tree has
been named after the actor and
environmentalist leonardo dicaprio you
vary opposite dicaprio a 13 foot tall
tree from the ilangilang family with
large yellow-green flowers on its trunk
was discovered in the ebbo forest in
cameroon scientists at q chose to honour
the actor after he campaigned to end
logging rights in the west african
air pollution in urban areas across the
globe contributed to 1.8 million excess
deaths in 2019 according to new research
two studies by scientists in the united
states looked at the effects of nitrogen
dioxide and fine particulate pollution
now that's known as pm 2.5 meaning
particulate matter smaller than 2.5
millionth of a meter now in 2019 these
particulate matter levels in cities
globally were 35 micrograms per cubic
meter meaning that air pollution levels
were seven times higher than guidelines
set out by the world health organization
the second study looked at nitrogen
dioxide gas also known as no2 now that's
an air pollutant mainly emitted by
vehicles industrial manufacturing and
agriculture
it revealed that in 2019 there were more
than 1.8 million asthma cases in
children associated with no2 levels and
in urban areas nitrogen dioxide was
responsible for 16
of all new child asthma cases
skies aisha zaheed has this report
ella was only nine years old when she
died following a severe asthma attack
in the last few years of her life she'd
been admitted to hospital 27 times and
suffered multiple seizures
in a landmark ruling in 2020 a coroner
said excessive air pollution contributed
to her death
we will never know really when
ella's problems really started the only
thing i can say to you was three months
before her seventh birthday that's when
we first noticed him she was born um
right right next to the south circler
and obviously that's where her final
breath was taken so for all of ella's
life she was breathing illegal air
air pollution led to 1.8 million excess
deaths in cities across the globe in
2019 according to new research in the
same year nearly 2 million asthma cases
among children worldwide were attributed
to nitrogen dioxide pollution and
modeling suggests 2.5 billion people are
living in urban areas with high levels
of air pollution
experts say the effects of this could be
catastrophic
the reason those uh air pollution is has
such a huge impact on our health is that
it really attacks almost every organ of
our body uh it comes in uh deep into our
lungs in some cases for the very fine
particles and ultra fine particles into
the bloodstream and it affects pretty
much anything from our brain and it
affects how uh particularly how
children's cognitive development
uh and lung development
is impaired so we need to push that that
that tendency so that uh we really
transform our city so that it's so easy
to walk by take public transportation
everywhere we have to do it
while the uk has seen reductions in air
pollution over the last decade the
government acknowledges there's still
more to do
it says it's committed to setting
stretching and ambitious targets
[Music]
ella's mum rosamund is campaigning for
change to come sooner rather than later
she hopes saving lives will be her
daughter's legacy aisha zahid sky news
deforestation in parts of west africa
could be leading to more severe
rainstorms and floods in the region
according to new research
the study found that forests helped to
regulate the local climate so the bigger
the deforested area the worse the storms
and extreme weather events are expected
to become more common as global warming
ticks up well meteorologist professor
chris taylor from the uk center for
ecology and hydrology led the research
and joins me now professor taylors what
did you discover then about the link
between deforestation and extreme
weather in west africa
so what we found was that deforestation
as you said is making storms become more
frequent and that effect in west africa
that effect is particularly strong along
the coastline we were looking in
countries such as sierra leone and ivory
coast
and the fact that these changes are
happening um
on the coastline is important because
that's where most people live
so the cities like freetown in sierra
leone which are growing at a phenomenal
rate
and they're especially vulnerable to
flash flooding from storms
um in 2017 there was a there was a
terrible event
where a flash flood triggered mudslides
and over a thousand people died
and are you seeing this pattern whatever
the terrain
yeah pretty much um i mean the key thing
is the
uh proximity of the ocean
to the area that's
deforested so the ocean is playing a key
key effect so we see it in mountainous
areas and flatter areas
so deforestation is having an effect on
the storms what about when that's tied
into the impact of climate change
well
um climate change is increasing
temperatures
and uh deforestation
uh increases temperatures also at a very
local scale
so that warming or
caused by the deforestation is warming
the land relative to the ocean
and that draws in more moisture from the
ocean
and when they every day uh when there's
a sea breeze when that
moisture is drawn in it triggers
thunderstorms and that's what's
happening here so the areas which are
have been deforested we saw the
frequency of storms was doubled over the
last 30 years compared to
30 or 40 percent in areas where there
was no deforestation over that period
and can you extrapolate that and look
into the future what's likely to happen
for sure so uh continuing uh
deforestation in this region will
continue to exacerbate that effect if
policies are put in place
for reforestation then we might expect
to see a reversal of that and a return
to the more natural balance of heating
and moistening of the atmosphere that
the forests provide
professor chris taylor thanks very much
indeed
well do stay tuned coming up here on the
daily climate show i'll be joined by a
specialist in global environmental
politics at cardiff university jen allen
and the director of anti-poverty charity
war on want assad raymond and we'll be
discussing why governments aren't doing
more to tackle deadly air pollution and
whether planting trees really is the
answer to tackling climate change
[Applause]
hello and welcome back to the daily
climate show on sky news and we're
getting straight to discussing the
climate issues of the day now with
specialists in global environmental
politics at cardiff university jen allen
and the director of anti-poverty charity
warren want assad raymond so very good
evening to both of you nice to see you
both
well first of all the numbers are stark
nearly 2 million excess deaths from air
pollution in 2019 according to a study
in the lancet well despite all our talk
on the climate crisis are we overlooking
an issue which poses a critical risk to
millions all over the world a gen to you
first of all these really are shocking
figures aren't they i mean is there
dangers around pollution
getting the levels of attention that you
think it should
it really isn't air pollution
is often sort of the the poor cousin or
the second sister depending on what
family member you want to choose to
climate change there's a lot of talk
about climate change the need for cities
to address climate change but tackling
air pollution
saves lives and it helps with our health
care systems and in tackling air
pollution that also helps to address
climate change there's examples around
the world where
if the source of air pollution is a coal
plant shutting down that coal plant also
helps the climate
i said there is a big crossover here
isn't there that the coal example gen
brings in there also moving
transportation to to electric vehicles
as well will help reduce pollution as
well but is climate change squeezing the
problems around pollution out of the
conversation do you think
i think it's actually a bigger question
of what do we mean when we talk about
climate change i think for too long
people have thought climate was really
something about you know parts per
million or just temperature rises where
we really should be talking about
climate is uh air pollution it's about
public transport it's right there you
know our health it's about the quality
of life so i think we need to have a
very very different conversation about
climate that includes air pollution not
only because of course it's material
impact on people's lives and on reducing
emissions but also because it's really
critical in ways that engages people in
understanding the importance of tackling
the climate crisis but also the benefits
that we have if we do that that good
quality air is vital for our health for
our quality of life and of course for
tackling the climate crisis well yeah
that makes it sound like a quite a
simple cell but doesn't it gen so who
should be stepping up here and doing
something about it is this about
national governments uh making sure
they've got the right policies in place
or is this about initiatives born out of
of cities
it's about cities and national
governments working together cities
can't do it alone they have
enormous challenges as it is they need
the support around investing in public
transit working to create walkable
livable
healthier cities and those big polluting
industries that's a national government
responsibility so there has to be a
partnership and a dialogue here it can't
be sort of a match back and forth about
everyone not taking responsibility for
it
and there are some successful projects
underway aren't there assad around the
world now there are things that work
there are plenty of solutions it's never
been a lack of solutions look we've seen
from barcelona to bogota to paris cities
being redesigned to put the primary of
people and their health away from you
know transport policies largely been
designed around cars and that's been
great you know we've seen healthier more
investment in cycling walking and public
transport including free public you know
initiatives that have played public
transport free to be able to engage
people but what has always been lacking
is the political will so while cities
may want to do this until national
governments are setting ambitious
targets putting plans in place and more
importantly providing the resources so
that cities can take the
sort of actions what we're going to see
is lots of conversations and lots of
promises to act but very very little of
these concrete policies it's never been
that we don't know what needs to be done
what's been lacking is the political
will from governments to do it and jen
briefly is part of the problem the fact
that the most polluted areas tend to be
the poorer areas and those are people
who feel they don't have such a voice
equity is such a big issue here there's
evidence around the world that polluting
industries tend to be cited in
black and hispanic neighborhoods in the
u.s
in first nations territories in canada
and so we can't just say air pollution
affects everyone the same
even though we all breathe the same air
it affects different groups
disproportionately and giving those
groups voice and bringing them into the
conversation is going to be fundamental
to addressing air pollution and the
climate crisis okay let's move on to our
second topic now shall we because we
heard earlier that the organization
trillion trees is launching a tool which
helps organizations work out whether
their plan to plant trees is doing
enough to reach their climate goals it's
an effort to make sure that offsetting
is about more than simply planting trees
it's also about reforestation and the
people doing it so gen as a general rule
can we say that tree planting schemes
are unequivocally a good thing
oh gosh if they are not a silver bullet
in any way uh problem number one is
trees burn
and when that happens when we have
forest fires all of the carbon that
they've soaked up for us
then is re-released into the atmosphere
so tree planting's good i'm not going to
ever discourage anyone from planting a
tree
but we can't use it as a band-aid that
we put over the climate crisis to sort
of try to absolve us of our sins as we
emit more and more into the atmosphere
i said what do you think i mean this
scheme does sound like it's it's very
good on the face of it but generally do
you agree with jen that it's like a
band-aid it gives people an easy way out
when they say it's fine i might do this
polluting thing but i'll plant some
trees
absolutely i agree with jen i mean what
we see increasingly is this we'll carry
on polluting and then we'll put these
other policies in place and somehow
they'll all equalize
out look the reality is you know the
carbon budget we've got
to keep temperature below 1.5 is about
10 years there is absolutely no room for
any offsets you know what we really need
is is actual real zero targets that
means real emissions reductions not this
idea you can kind of go unlike a lot of
the big dirty energy companies are all
saying we'll carry on digging for more
oil and gas and coal as long as we can
plant some trees somewhere else as
jen said look you know trees burn but
more importantly also misses the real
problem of deforestation and
deforestation as the u.n has said the
overwhelming majority of trees are being
cut down is because of our agricultural
system industrial agriculture it's
because of our mining it's because of
roads and dams and until you deal with
those and the best solution actually to
deal with those is actually land rights
for indigenous communities if we did
that we'd be doing much better in terms
of protecting what we've got and that's
the real important thing we have to
protect the forests that we have these
initiatives to plant more trees i'm not
gonna as jen said i'm not going to dis
say that they aren't you know useful but
they are not the policy solution
but jen there are some industries that
are struggling to make the technological
breakthroughs to make them um less
likely to pollute and
increase climate change so
given that we've got those are there
other solutions we can look at other
carbon things we could focus on
peatlands or mangroves or or soil
restoration
there are some sectors that are called
the the hard to abate sectors they're
ones where we don't quite have the tech
yet
it doesn't mean that there's nothing
that we can do i mean there was an
example a few months ago about greener
steel so the the steel industry which is
one of those hard to abate sectors
also has potential options in-house to
reduce emissions in the first place
uh yeah we can invest in peatlands and
mangroves
there's technologies maybe but at the
end of the day there's only so much that
mother nature can help us here because
at the same time that we're asking
mother nature to help us absorb all of
this carbon dioxide we're also hurting
the planet and weakening its ability to
do that okay so
we really need to sort of reduce
emissions first sorry to cut you off jen
we are out of time but jen allen assad
roman always good to talk to you both
thanks so much for your time tonight we
appreciate it
well that's everything from the daily
climate show for today tomorrow i'll be
joined by climate activist laurie young
and professor of political economy at
the university of sheffield michael
jacobs thanks very much for watching
we'll be back at the same time tomorrow
see you then
[Music]
you